today on the matt well show amazon pulls
some dirty tricks to suppress and censor
my children's book but it still manages
to become the number one book in the
entire country also joe biden is
considering a hail mary pass before the
midterms student loan forgiveness we'll
talk about why that is a horrible idea
and speaking of horrible ideas joe biden
also tells a group of teachers that that
the kids in their classrooms are their
kids not somebody else's kids the kids
belong to them also hollywood actress
megan fox proudly discusses her satanic
blood drinking rituals but i was told
satanism in hollywood is a conspiracy
theory we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt welsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
well uh in this economy it's not an easy
time for anybody especially small
business owners and that's why you got
to have everything locked down and
especially if you're a small business
owner you know
how important it is to have an effective
marketing strategy constant contact is a
digital marketing platform that helps
small businesses and nonprofits of all
sizes build grow and succeed with email
marketing contact contact management
industry leading list growth tools
social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers
find new ones and sell online all from
one easy to use platform that's
the name of the game here is that it's
easy they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing with a 97 deliverability rate
you can rest assured that your customers
and potential customers are getting the
right messages at the right time with a
simple interface constant contact's easy
to use platform makes contact management
easier than ever there list growth tools
help you find a bigger audience fast
lead generation landing pages text to
join and social media ads are proven to
grow your list and drive engagement with
your brand with thousands of
integrations you can sync constant
contacts tools with the tools you're
already using powerful automation tools
help you send the right message to the
right person at the right time every
time to start your free digital
marketing trial today visit
constantcontact.com
you know there are some who would argue
that it's not the smartest long-term
career strategy to aggressively
antagonize and purposefully make an
enemy out of one of the wealthiest most
powerful corporations in the world
and um it's even more reckless you might
say when this corporation
happens to control 90 of the book sales
in the country and you make part of your
living by selling books
and you might be right about all of that
but um all i can say is that still it's
totally worth it there have been
a number of big developments since we
talked yesterday about the leaked videos
uh over at amazon of an amazon meeting
where the employees complained and
whined and at one point actually cried
over my children's book as much as i'd
love to play those clips again um i'm
not gonna do that but you can always go
and watch them if you want and they're
crying about my children's book johnny
the walrus of course which is available
for sale
over at amazon uh you go to
johnnywalrus.com
they call the book triggering traumatic
uh problematic
harmful they were also incensed that the
book was originally categorized as an
lgbt children's book and even more in
sense that i was as they claimed
bragging about it publicly and trolling
them they claimed
now i personally take great exception to
any accusation
that i have bragged or trolled that is
simply
not the kind of thing that i would do
does that sound like me come on
but that's how they interpreted it and
they were very upset
now after the show yesterday um some
more developments amazon
sent an email to our publishing division
dw books and they informed us that our
ads for johnny the walrus have been
banned from the platform
they said that we were conducting that
they rather were conducting a quote
unquote periodic review
which just so happens to coincide
directly with these embarrassing videos
coming out
and me making fun of them for it so just
like at the same time coincidentally
there's this totally random and periodic
review that they conducted and they and
they discovered that oh we actually
can't run ads for the book anymore
because it's not appropriate
the ads are inappropriate here's what
the email actually says this is what it
says exactly
your ad is not appropriate for all
audiences
i mean despite the fact that it's
literally a board book for preschoolers
but anyway to ensure a good customer
experience we reserve the right to
restrict ads that contain elements that
may not be appropriate for all audiences
this may include erotica
content on sexual preferences such as
bdsm
incestuous relationships sexual contact
with persons under the age of 18
self-help content such as dating get
rich quick or weight loss books or
content that promotes endorses or
incites potentially dangerous or harmful
activity
i have to say credit words do
i do appreciate how they have put
self-help books on the same tier as bdsm
and incest self-help books are just as
disgraceful and gross as that they're
saying and and i don't disagree
necessarily
but which category does johnny the
walrus fall into
like
what do you think johnny the walrus is
if that's how you're interpreting it
whatever amazon thinks i can assure any
potential buyer of this book
there is no bdsm in johnny the walrus
there is no incest there is no sexual
content of any kind at all actually
it also doesn't promote dangerous
activities it promotes the opposite
so what is is it a self-help book is
that what they're saying
is it self-help for walruses
is that the claim i don't know
the answer of course is that the book is
none of these things and they know that
it's none of these things the book and
the ad are 100 appropriate for all ages
even by the standards of amazon's own
policies
they're removing it out of out of
revenge it's an act of revenge quite
explicitly and obviously and if it
wasn't already explicit enough they also
declassified the book
from the children's category
so it's no longer listed on amazon as a
children's book
amazon has put it into the political
commentary section of the site now
ironically
them placing it in the political
commentary section is itself political
commentary on their part it's
editorialization
about the book they don't like the book
they don't personally think people
should read it to their kids so they're
not going to list it as a children's
book
even though it unequivocally is just
that
like this is not what booksellers are
supposed to do
uh if you're going to carry the book
and it's a children's book then then any
more than if someone wrote a sci-fi book
and you didn't personally think it was
great sci-fi you're like i'm not going
to put it in that section i'll put in
this section over here
but you might not like it but that is
without a doubt the genre of the book
um in fact my book is significantly more
age-appropriate than many other
children's books on the sites which are
allowed to be advertised as well but
amazon wasn't done
next and again this all happened
yesterday um next amazon turned its
sites on my other book what is a woman
which will be released in june and is
also available for sale on amazon you go
to what is women.com
um they conducted another conveniently
timed periodic review so these are two
periodic reviews that they happened to
conduct yesterday while this was
happening and they sent another email to
dw books announcing that our ad campaign
for that book has been banned as well um
their reasoning was slightly more
specific they say your ad contains
content that appears to infer or claim
to diagnose treat reverse or question
gender identity or sexual orientation
now of course
they haven't read the book so they
couldn't possibly know if it contains
those kinds of
things all the book all the book cover
does is ask a question what is a woman
they appear to be admitting i guess that
the simple question what is a woman
that question itself may have the effect
of reversing gender identity
like just asking the question what is a
woman
the question itself invalidates gender
identity
which appears to be what they're saying
and in fact they're right about that if
that is what they're saying
but um what does that say about gender
identity in that case
as for the content of the actual book it
actually contains mostly my
conversations with other people
including several supposed experts quote
unquote on that side of the conversation
i mean it's a book with um interviews
with
uh a gender affirming therapist and
gender affirming pediatricians
gender affirming surgeons to use
their euphemisms for all those things
but you know the difference is that i
don't blindly accept everything these
experts say i ask them
questions skeptical questions as
questions you know questions are
supposed to be skeptical by their nature
and apparently that's not allowed
now we're not taking any of this lying
down though um amazon didn't like how
johnny the walrus was originally
classified on their site so we decided
if you didn't like that then you're
really not going to like this amazon we
decided to classify my what is a woman
book
as a biology text
after all contagi brown jackson said
that you know only a biologist is
qualified to speak about the subject it
is a it's a biological
subject and so it made sense that our
book is it's it's therefore a biology
book it's a biology textbook
and um so that's how we
listed it and right now as you can see
what is a woman is the best-selling
biology book on amazon as it currently
stands
um i'm sure the employees absolutely
love that and they can take it out of
that category which i'm sure they're
gonna do but it will forever and always
have the distinction as a best-selling
biology book we got it in there we got
the screenshot there it is
i may and this means that for the rest
of my life and you know that i'll make
good on this this is a a credential that
i'm going to bring with me
i can now start any argument i have
with someone anytime i have to make a
point
i can say well
as the best-selling author of a or
rather as the author of a best-selling
biology book
dot dot dot
meanwhile johnny the walrus itself in
spite of the efforts to suppress it by
amazon became and is still the number
one book overall across the entire
platform it is number one on the best
seller list overall
and um given that as mentioned amazon
controls nearly all of the book sales in
america we can say
without a doubt that johnny the walrus
is right now the best-selling book
period in the entire country out of all
the books being sold out of the
thousands of books that is number one
and we achieved this even though no
brick and mortar stores would go
anywhere near this book
and even though amazon doesn't want it
and is doing everything it can to censor
it and suppress it is still the number
one book in america now
this is all extremely
funny and i tend to focus a lot
on the humor of it because that's the
most fun thing to talk about but
we would be missing i think a big part
of the point if we concentrated solely
on the humor of it
the fact is that
the number one book in the country
is a pre-school board book
satirizing left-wing gender ideology
now that would have been unthinkable up
until
well right now when it actually happened
and i think this is just another line of
evidence
that the cultural tide is beginning to
turn that's not to say that the battle
is won by any means as i am constantly
reminding everyone and myself if there's
going to be a victory in this in this
war
that victory will be generations down
the line you and i
will live and die in a culture that is
fundamentally hostile to us
that's the reality so you might as well
strap in and learn to enjoy the fight
that's the record that's the advice i
give everyone when they tell well how
are we going to win what do we
just learn learn to enjoy fighting
because that's all you're gonna have
it's it's that's it
you're not living in uh in peace time
and you never will be living in those
times
maybe your grandchildren will though if
you fight hard enough
and that's that's enough for me i could
take solace in that
and though victory is far down the line
that doesn't mean we can uh that we're
not able to to make progress towards
that end which i think we are right now
johnny the walrus is even i will admit
a very very small
salvo in the war but even so
a win is a win
um nothing wrong with enjoying them when
they come
i know i am and in fact i had a chance
to celebrate last night i was speaking
at wisconsin superior
and it was a great great turnout great
speech
great event
right outside the building
a group of leftist protesters had
gathered to scream about how i'm a
terrible guy and all the rest of it uh
and they'd been out there for a while so
they ordered pizza for themselves
and my producer sean went out and um and
got me a slice
as you can see and um
i imagine the protesters were not happy
to find out that i took some of their
pizza
but
they should take heart because they fed
a best-selling children's author
and that is an act of charity
and it's another win for for both of us
i think
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you've been listening to my
show for a while you know that i am an
activist uh on many topics but probably
first and foremost and most importantly
i'm an activist against the lazy grocery
shoppers who don't put their grocery
carts away well um here's some tragic
news that you might have already heard
from me but i'll tell you again the
grocery carts
they did attack me in my own car in an
act of vengeance when i was pulling out
of my parking spot a rogue grocery cart
crashed into my car leaving my front
bumper scratched
almost totaling the car well i mean
there's a scratch but you know it's
close enough
there are two lessons you can take away
from this one don't be lazy put your
shopping carts away two you can solve an
issue like mine quickly and without
breaking the bank by just visiting
rockauto.com they have touch-up paint in
pens that are easy to use as a magic
marker
that's how easy they are and
rockauto.com look talk about easy very
easy to find everything you need there
it's an online family-owned business
that sells all the auto parts you could
ever possibly need that are specific to
your own vehicle their prices are
shockingly reasonable and their shipping
is quick so no matter what's going on
with your car you can trust rockauto to
get what you need and get it fast
rockauto.com has a
very user-friendly website and they make
it easy to pick the right parts for your
specific card you'll see photos specs
and installation tips so you can feel
confident that you're choosing the
correct parts for your vehicle every
single time
so what are you waiting for it's as
simple as this just go to rockauto.com
for all of your auto parts needs today
and remember when you go there to write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box so they know that i'm the one that
sent you that's rockauto.com to shop for
auto parts today
um you know another thing just another
quick note about this is i was thinking
about this today too and just go going
back to the more the more fun thing to
talk about which is just how funny all
this is
um
that that is another that's a kind of
underrated cultural
shift it's an underrated but but but i
think quite significant cultural shift
that's happened over the last few years
and that is that um on the right now
we are
by far and away
funnier than the left and uh we're
better at mocking and satirizing and
trolling than they are
miles better at it
and we're having a lot more fun too at
the same time
and that is that's a like i said a very
significant change actually and it has
not always been this way
so it's not something you could take for
granted by any means in fact for most of
my life it was it was quite the opposite
where the right had the stereotype of
being these kind of stuffy
self-serious school moms who are you
know aren't laughing about anything
aren't having a good time at all just
constantly complaining about stuff and
that stereotype was uh was was not
without some basis you know
but there's been things have just
changed radically and pretty quickly
over the last few years
where at this point i can't think like
what's the last
funny kind of stunt
uh trolling thing mockery
even meme i mean what's the last funny
thing you've seen from the left i can't
even think of
think of what it would be
they're not having any fun at all
i think there's a lot of reasons for
that one is that they're this is just
their their ideology is suffocating them
and it just it strangles the humor out
of everything you're just you're not a
left you want to be
a pure
leftist at this point you're not allowed
to laugh about anything
everything is off the table everything's
offensive and um
that's part of it part of it is also i
think
for for us the the advantage of being
um
kind of in the
the cultural rebel position being in the
counterculture position
where they run all the institutions they
have all the power so that kind of puts
them in automatically this kind of
defensive posture where they're
defending what they've already gained
and that's just not it's not as much fun
and uh there aren't as many targets for
mockery i guess also so
i think that's also a good thing all
right let's go speaking of things that
are really funny of course elon musk
taking over twitter is just
hilarious and everything about it has
been great but he tweeted something
yesterday that i i just wanted to know
because i actually disagree with him
here um it's a
nice in theory but here's what he says
he says for twitter to deserve public
trust it must be politically neutral
which effectively means upsetting the
far right and the far left equally now
the first part of this tweet here i
agree with um it should be politically
neutral that's what i want it to be i
don't want
i've said all along that we already have
there are social media platforms out
there that are quote-unquote
conservative platforms and they've got a
conservative bent and you know a
conservative mission and i don't use
those platforms i don't i i don't find
them interesting they're not fun to use
um i don't really i don't need to be i
don't want to be in an echo chamber that
takes away almost the entire point for
me or even being on these platforms in
the first place they become culturally
irrelevant
because you've kind of just you you've
segregated yourself from the cultural
conversation
and so i don't like him and i wouldn't
want there's never any chance of twitter
turning into that but i wouldn't want
that i what i what i actually want
twitter to be is politically neutral i
just don't want twitter have any
political stance at all
i want it to be basically what it was in
the early days in the wild west days of
twitter and of social media generally i
mean there was a time when pretty much
every social media platform was
basically
this way
where you know you could kind of go and
say what you want and there were some
rules
but not a lot
and everybody knew what the rules were
and they were pretty basic like you
can't go and threaten to kill somebody
or do anything like that
so i would like to go back to that
actual political neutrality you get out
of the way you provide the platform and
then we let us mix it up and and do what
we're gonna do
now so that that part i agree
it's the second part that i don't agree
where he says well if we're politically
neutral that effectively means upsetting
the far right in the far left equally no
it doesn't
political neutrality does not upset the
far right i am on the far right i can't
pretend to speak for everybody
uh in in my
in my camp
but i certainly am on the far right i
embrace that
and i can tell you that that's not how i
see it it doesn't upset me it's exact
that's exactly what i want
and i think in fact i can speak for most
people on the quote far right because
that's uh i i have not i haven't heard
from anybody on the far right who wants
twitter to become this conservative
um
vehicle
i haven't heard anyone say they want
twitter to become a vehicle for
conservatism
so actually on the right that's what we
want we just want you to get out of the
way
and stop trying to referee and police
everything it's on the left on the other
hand they are upset by neutrality they
don't want that they're actually very
specific about that
they're not hiding it but there might
have been a time when they hit it but
they don't anymore they do not want
neutrality
this is where the phrase silence is
violence comes from
you don't often hear people on the right
saying that that is almost in that's if
someone is saying that 99 times out of
100 that's somebody on the left saying
silence is violence and you don't even
need to know the context you just know
that it's somebody on the left
and that's what they mean if if twitter
were to uh become actually neutral that
means that twitter itself is being
silent about the issues and that's
violence
you know and so for example a neutral
stance
would be twitter allows us to talk about
gender
and um
and so god forbid you could go on
twitter
and refer to a male who identifies as a
woman and say well that's a that's a man
the neutral position for twitter is to
say nothing about that like
you can say that then the left can make
their claim and say no it's actually a
woman and we can have the debate
but the left doesn't want that
no they want twitter to prevent you from
saying that at all
they don't want to have the conversation
they know they can't have the
conversation they can't win the debate
so neutrality is not what they want
um there is one side
of the ideological divide which is
opposed to neutrality
and opposed actually actually opposed to
free speech and that is and that is the
left without a question
all right
let's go here from uh
cnbc it says the tens of millions of
americans saddled with student loans may
finally hear soon what the buy
administration has decided to do if
anything on debt forgiveness white house
press secretary jen pasake said on
monday's press briefing not a single
person's country has paid a dime on
federal student loans since the
president took office she went on to say
that president joe biden would make a
decision about any cancellation of
student debt before the conclusion of
that pause on student loans
um
let's see
although biden has expressed skepticism
about sweeping student loan forgiveness
in the past another development this
week suggests he may be warming up to
the idea when the topic came up monday
with the congressional hispanic caucus
the president indicated he was currently
looking to provide some form of student
debt cancellation according to multiple
reports democrats and advocates have put
intense pressure on the president to act
ahead of midterms pointing out that
student debt cancellation is a campaign
promise he can deliver on without
congress while much of his agenda has
been stymied in the house and senate so
he's spoken out in the past have been
against the idea of student debt
forgiveness quote unquote cancellation
and
both of these terms are euphemisms
neither of them actually reflect the
reality of what this would be it's not
just forgiveness
um the government can't what does that
even mean for the government to forgive
the loan it's not going to cancel it
this is
transferring the debt
somewhere else
and there's only one one other place it
can go
and that is to the taxpayers
and the government can't pay off the
debt because the government
only has the money that it takes from us
so
that's what we're talking about it's
taking the debt it's not canceling it
not at all
if it were possible as i've said before
if there were a magic wand where you
could just
make the debt go away and that's it it's
just gone there's no other consequences
no one has to pay it
i'm still not sure that i would support
using the magic wand because the the
this is still an agreement that people
made that we're just erasing
um but
at least there's a conversation we could
have in that case if the magic wand
existed it doesn't and so instead we're
talking about taking the debt and
transferring it from the person
who chose to take on the debt and agreed
to it
and bought the product
and has ostensibly benefited from the
product or at least has the potential to
benefit from them from it
and transferring that debt to people who
did not
make that agreement or sign on the
dotted line
and also very importantly here do not
have the product that was purchased
and the product is the college degree
the fact that so many college degrees
end up being basically worthless is true
and that's that's a separate
conversation
and the fact that college degrees are so
often worthless that's that's the reason
why that's not that's not an argument
for debt forgiveness
that's actually an argument against debt
forgiveness
because another problem with the quote
debt forgiveness or debt transferal
is that now you're just encouraging more
of the bad stupid reckless behavior
across the board that got us in this
position in the first place
when you wave your magic wand which
doesn't even really exist all you're
doing is encouraging more of it
validating it
um when the real solution to the college
debt loan crisis as i've said many times
is um
there is there is no there is no good
solution that's going to do anything to
reverse what's already happened in the
past
but looking towards the future the
solution is to stop shuffling
all you know almost every kid into the
university system regardless of whether
they're going to benefit from college
education or not
the whole practice of sending 18 year
old kids into college when they don't
even know what they want to do with
their lives what they're interested in
what their passions are what they want
to study
i mean we just we just we this is
another thing we take for granted but
it's very common
of course to have college freshmen who
have already taken out the loans and
their income they've committed to this
for four years
and they have no idea what they even
want to major in they don't they don't
know what like they have no clue
they don't know what they want to study
they don't know what they certainly have
no idea what they want to do with the
rest of their lives
and then and then we say well well
that's normal that's okay no it's not i
mean it is normal but it shouldn't be
and it's not it's not okay
you've made this massive commitment
and you don't even know why you made it
that's a huge problem
it's like
you know it's like if um
i don't know you're at some really
bizarre flea market and you you stumble
across some contraption and you have no
idea what this you could tell that it
might do something it's some kind of
machine you're not sure we have no idea
what it does
and you ask the person how much for that
machine and they say oh it'd be 150 000
who would say that it's a good idea to
buy it
you don't know what it does you don't
know how you're going to use it you
don't know if you can use it you have no
idea if it'll benefit you or not i mean
maybe it'll change your life forever and
uh make everything better maybe not and
but you can spend 150 000 on it
in no other context
would we encourage that kind of decision
among 18 year old kids or among anybody
i don't care how old you are this is
what we do with with colleges the
solution is to stop doing that
and then still until we stop doing it
this problem is not going to go away
but
i can pretty much guarantee that this
debt transferal some version of it is
going to happen because despite what
biden has said in the past
um he is now and the democrats general
are floundering we're getting towards
the midterms and they need to pull a
rabbit out of the hat and this this is
this is it this is this is one of the
things um is debt forgiveness although i
think it's going to massively
politically backfire for them
because debt forgiveness quote unquote
is
among other things a welfare program for
the upper class
um
that is
by far and away you know the the top
50
40 30
they're going to benefit the most
from
college loan forgiveness because they
have most of the college loans
this is certainly not something that's
going to predominantly
help poor people lower middle class
people blue collar people
many of whom had didn't go to college
and have still been able to find success
in life and now you're going to go to
them and say okay you have to take on
this debt
for a product that you didn't even
purchase you you chose a different path
in life
you chose maybe to go into a trade
and um
and and learn a skill
and now you're working and you're
applying that skill and you're
providing for your family and you're
helping society that's the decision that
you made it was the right decision
but now i'm going to take the burden of
other people's bad decisions and put it
on you
i think that's going to be a very
politically unpopular
decision
um and that's all this is it is
welfare for the for the upper class
for upper-class spoiled brats
who made a decision bought a product and
now don't want to live with the
consequences and they want to
shirk their responsibilities and they
want us they want to uh put the burden
take their burdens and put it on other
people put it on their their neighbors
all right
another thing from biden speaking of
very politically unpopular here's biden
yesterday addressing teachers and i want
you to to listen to what he says here
and speaking of midterms one thing i'll
say is that i really hope
that joe biden takes this message and
the democrats they take this messaging
and take it right into the midterms
please do i beg you listen to this
have the best educated
public in the world
have our students
gain confidence enough to know what they
can do
to reach in
we have an obligation
we have a location to help them
teach
and reach their potential
you've heard me say it many times
about our children but it's true they're
all our children
and the reason you're the teachers of
the year is because you recognize that
they're not somebody else's children
they're like yours when they're in the
classroom
you represent a profession
that helps them gain the confidence
the confidence they believe they can do
anything
they're not somebody else's children
they're yours when they're in the
classroom
please
joe that take that that that that's a
winner yeah please take that all the way
to the midterms
they're not and what does it mean by
somebody else's it means the parents
they're not somebody else's
the parents
no they're your children because they're
in the classroom
um and that is that's this is not a gaff
you didn't misspeak here that's exactly
what democrats think
that is precisely the leftist position
is that when the kids are in the
classroom they're in the government
classrooms government building
government school system and that means
that they belong to the government that
is their position they're not usually
quite that explicit about it but they
get pretty close
and this is a moment when
joe biden was very explicit about it
that's how they see it
you send your children to us and they
our
they are ours
and not only when they're in the
classroom by the way but even when they
leave
they're still hours
that's how they see it
and it's it's good it's it's very good
to know now they're they're wrong about
that of course
you are entrusted if you're a teacher in
a public school classroom
um you know depending on what grade
level you might
you might have the kids entrusted to you
for 45 minutes at a time you have a
different group of kids 45 minutes and
they are entrusted to you for a specific
purpose
not as an adoptive parent it's not as
foster care
not even as daycare at least that's not
what what schools are supposed to be
even though even though they're treated
that way
you are simply entrusted to impart
certain information to the kids
on a certain subject that's all you're
supposed to be doing that's the only
that's your whole job
and not not to say that it's just that
it's a small or minor thing it's quite a
noble job to do an important one
if you actually do the job you're
supposed to do and take it seriously
and don't try to do more than that job
by taking these children under your wing
and turning them into your own kind of
de facto children because they're not
but it isn't it is
crucial for us to understand that um
this is how the government education
system sees it
and when you send your kids to the
school even though they are still your
kids you are sending them into a system
that believes
that they have ownership
um
of the parental
rights that actually belong to you
all right speaking of which
from the daily wire rhode island
democrats are pushing legislation that
would teach children about
pleasure-based sexual relations
pleasure-based sexual relations
with the support of left-wing groups the
legislation senate bill 2285 would amend
current law so that culturally
appropriate courses in quote family life
or sex education are taught to children
beginning in sixth grade when students
are about 11 or 12 years old
quote
teachings would recognize pleasure-based
sexual relations
different sexual orientations and be
inclusive of same-sex relationships the
act would also provide that instruction
include gender gender expression gender
identity and the harm of negative gender
stereotypes
this is what they want to do in
rhode island rhode island state senator
tierra mack a democrat representing
providence one of the primary sponsors
of the bill has cited her southern
abstinence-only sex education as a
reason for pushing
sb2285 she said there was no
conversation about what it meant to be
gay or what a healthy relationship
looked like
sex education is about learning about
gender and gender roles about what it's
like to grow up in a single parent
family it's about all the things i wish
i had gotten it's about knowing i wasn't
alone
that's what she says and in fact here
matt i think we have a
video of her she's interviewing talking
a little bit about
about this pleasure-based sex ed and uh
here's what she has to say about that
an opportunity came up to teach sex ed
um through a program um at the
university called sexual health advocacy
through peer educators to teach sex ed
um to local high school students and i
did that my sophomore year um after um
applying my freshman year i'm like well
if i didn't know this like there are
people out there like me who literally
have no idea how to talk about their
body how to access agency and how to
actually practice autonomy in whatever
way they want to do it and for me that
was unlocking conversations about my
body my sexuality and my identity in a
safe and um culturally sensitive and
respectful environment and also sharing
that with 15 year olds who at the time
are yearning to have that conversation
and i taught sex ed all throughout the
rest of my um
college career and then i went to go on
to teach high school math and i still
was teaching sex education
and at the time at the same time still
working on issues surrounding
reproductive health rights and access
from local abortion funding work and to
now being on the board of abortion fund
um and being an employee of planned
parenthood of southern new england it's
been a core of my work
yeah so that's what she wants this is
what you think sex ed should be it
should be about as she said in the in
the article it's about knowing i'm not
alone it's about it's about discovering
your body or whatever else she's talking
about um
no sex ed is is
not supposed to be any of that in fact
there should you know we're at a point
now where you just have to get sex out
of the schools completely
for for every grade level
you know k through 12 no sex out of any
kind get it all out this is not um you
know no no i'm not saying let's have
abstinence-only education instead of
this instead of the so-called
comprehensive sex education
no i don't want that either um i don't i
don't i don't need
if i set my kids to public school which
i don't but if i did i would need
teachers
talking to my kids about how to abstain
from sex and the advantages of that
that's not a conversation that i'm going
to trust to strangers
okay i can have that conversation i
don't need you to do it i don't trust
you to do it
uh but of course we're way beyond
abstinence education
and they want this which is on the other
the total other end of the spectrum my
point is
just take the whole spectrum and throw
it out
um
we just cannot trust these perverts
to
have conversations with kids about sex
at all
okay so
there should be no
subject no course called sex ed
you want to talk about reproduction
you talk about that in biology
you want to talk about the anatomy
talk about that that's also a science
discussion so you can cover those
but anything beyond that
um
even if in theory
you know there there could be a version
of a sex ed class that's appropriate in
theory which i haven't even heard what
that version would be
even if you could in theory figure out
such such a curriculum you cannot trust
the teachers
to do it
you just can't as as we see here because
they have taken this
keep keep something else in mind here
that for them
sex
and their sex life and their sexual
orientation
and their gender identity like that's
that's their whole existence
that's everything that's all they care
about so so everything gets wrapped up
in that that's also their religion
and that's why she says oh sex is about
it's about knowing sex is about knowing
yourself and knowing you're not alone
you know what
what is knowing you're not alone have to
do with sex ed what are you talking
about
well it's because her whole identity and
life and everything is wrapped up in sex
and that's yet another reason why you
can't trust these people to talk to kids
about sex
speaking of her whole life being wrapped
up in sex there's another another tweet
from this tierra mack character if we
put this up um just to give you an idea
of like what her priorities are
so this is what she tweeted a couple
days ago she says i'm a single queer tr
hold on a second i'm a single
queer train advocate
like what
a
queer trainer so she's an advocate for
queer trains
now she doesn't want those you know
normal hetero heteronormative trains
she's an advocate for queer trains get
on the queer train everybody
she says i'm a single queer train
advocate who's desperate for better
train service
and high-speed rail options to nyc on
the weekends exclusively for the queer
dating scene
better trains now
what god's name
uh yet again exhibit a no it's not
exhibit a that's ex you know that's
exhibit uh
5 million 772 or whatever of why you
can't trust these people to talk to your
kids about so you can't trust them at
all with anything
just these lunatic
absolute lunatics this is an elected
democrat i guess if i could decipher
this
she's demanding
her own train service
to facilitate her sex life
she's demanding an exclusive train
service
so that she can go to new york city and
um
have sex with women
that's what she's saying
this is an elected democrat
my god
uh and that's another one democrats take
that into the midterms too please
take student loan forgiveness uh they're
not your kids and queer trains
i think that should be your platform
right there bring that right into
midterms hop on the queer train
go right into midterms with that please
do
let's get to the comment section
um jasmine says daddy walsh is the
actual troll king he never ceases to top
his last troll his debut as an author
and movie maker might even top
raising money for aoc's grandma well
like i said we're just
you know the aoc thing will it's it's a
smaller you know it's a much smaller
scale some of the other stuff stuff
we've done
that might always have pride of place in
my own heart um just because i i enjoyed
that one so much and it was so much fun
but really all this stuff and uh you
know also being a
another one we can add to the list now
is being
a best-selling biologist so i'm loving
that as well
uh but
jinji responds to um the comment from
jasmine and says is being the troll king
something to be proud of
doesn't sound like something a genuine
christian would want
is there anything in uh
you know i've i've read through the
gospels quite a bit and i don't remember
maybe it's in the epistles is there
something in there about
thou shalt not troll is that is that a
un-christian
no you know i i think what you're
getting at is that um
is when we talk about trolling now
there's a version of trolling
where you're just saying stuff you don't
even believe
because you want attention
and there's quite a lot of that kind of
trolling that goes on the internet
that's not what i'm doing
okay that's not the trolling that i
engage in and also
heartedly support
um because everything that i'm saying i
absolutely believe
and when you're in the troll sweet spot
okay it's when you really when you've
really threaded the needle
is when
you're joking about it but you're also
being 100 serious at the same time and
so that's pretty much that's basically
like everything i do it's i'm joking but
i'm also not at all
johnny the walrus
it's a total joke but also not at all
at the same exact time okay
and so if you're being genuine
and you're standing for what you believe
in then i'm not quite sure i see how
that sort of quote trolling
uh somehow betrays my christian faith
now
it's kind of aggressive
it could be it could take a mocking tone
at times
it could be a little bit ruthless
but that is what we need
to do
you know we talk about the event one of
the advantages that we have as i
mentioned before is that on the left
like they're just not funny at all
they're not having any fun
and um and that's an advantage to us but
the other advantage is that on the left
you know these are also as we saw with
the amazon videos
these are very soft people
many of them quite mentally damaged
and what that means is that if we want
to win and have some real victories
there's an opportunity there
if we're smart about it and clever and
also yeah a little bit ruthless
because they're soft and they're
sensitive so we have to be the opposite
of that
and that's what it calls for right now
remember like i said this is not
this is not um
we're not living in peace times
let's see
the crazy thing is that if elon musk was
african-american and looked
african-american all the left would be
celebrating him taking over twitter
well that's not necessarily true at all
in fact
you're saying if elon musk was like
actually black then they would all be
celebrated
no no they wouldn't not necessarily
it depends on his ideology i mean if
elon musk was black and had the ideology
of clarence thomas
they would not be celebrating that in
the least bit so that's an important
point here about um
you know they're the kind of racial
preferences that they have on the left
and they do have them but that is all
filtered through the lens of ideology
and so if you're on the right or
perceived to be on the right or just
simply not on the left they hate you no
matter what your skin color is and in
fact
if you're not white they'll hate you
even more because on top of disagreeing
with you they also there's also this
this sense of betrayal they have because
they think that they own you and that
you owe yourself to them and so on top
of everything they also feel betrayed by
you and they consider you a race trader
so they're actually going to hate you
more just talk to you know ask candace
owens about it they're going to hate you
even more because they think that you
owe yourself to them
um
dirk says all my kids genuinely love
johnny the walrus the one-year-old is
especially fond of pretending to be able
to read it which i feel is
thematically appropriate my daughter
legitimately loves the book also by my
two-year-old and uh she has it basically
memorized and she actually does
love the book i don't she doesn't really
understand
that she's a little bit biased she
doesn't understand that i wrote it like
she hasn't she doesn't quite grasp that
because she's always bringing the book
over to me to show me the book and show
me things in the book that she thinks
are great like it's the first time i've
seen it but she does draw the connection
between the zookeeper character and
daddy so she sees that daddy is in the
book and so it's one of the reasons but
even if but even if without that i still
think it's a book that all kids can love
um
let's see
michael says i love matt's analogy of
men with rough hands i met a girl and we
went on a date and she said that i had
smooth hands i knew that was a lie
because i do construction and my hands
are basically sandpaper i never met up
with her again well that's the only way
to respond to that i mean that's uh talk
about trying to take someone's talk talk
about emasculating someone
there's there's no better way to do that
so i think you made the right decision
michael let's get down to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know if it seems like hollywood is
infested with satanists well that's
because uh it is in fact we can add this
to the list which is a very very long
list indeed at this point of things that
are erroneously written off as
conspiracy theories but actually are not
and have turned out to be entirely true
hollywood is indeed satanic case in
point the actress megan fox now granted
i call her an actress but i couldn't
tell you for sure if she
actually has starred in any films over
the past 10 years and even back when she
was starring in films it would be a bit
of a stretch to call her an actress
but that's all academic i suppose fox
was never famous for her acting talent
she um you know her primary skill has
always been simply walking around and
looking attractive
and to her credit she's always done a
pretty good job on both counts these
days though she's added another
credential to her resume um she has
expanded her repertoire and now she also
on top of walking around looking
attractive she also has a weird
boyfriend
and this is kind of like her main thing
now and what seems to be getting her
into the headlines is that she has a
weird boyfriend fox is dating somebody
named machine gun kelly now i couldn't
begin to tell you anything about machine
gun kelly nor whether machine gun kelly
is his christian name but i do know that
fox has described him as
a handsome demonic creature
unless you think that she meant that
ironically in some way or as a joke
here she is in rather explicit terms in
a recent interview um talking about
their vampiric
sexual habits listen
drank each other's blood might
mislead people or like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood it's just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes
only
it is used for a reason and it is
controlled where it's like let's shed a
few drops of blood i need to drink it
he's much more haphazard and hectic and
chaotic where he's willing to just like
cut his chest open with broken glass and
be like take my soul
let me bleed on you
it doesn't not happen let me tell you
maybe not exactly like that but it a
version of that has happened
many times
oh for ritual purposes only well okay
then
as long as you're consuming each other's
blood for ritual purposes then it's not
creepy at all
oh wait no right that's that's actually
the creepiest possible explanation you
could have given
not that there could have been a
non-creepy one
um fox admits that she participates in
blood drinking rituals with her
boyfriend
she doesn't feel embarrassed about
sharing this information with the world
partly because she's not capable of
shame but also because she lives and
moves in a world where that kind of
thing is not considered bizarre in fact
this only came up because she mentioned
matter of factly in an instagram post a
few months ago after mr machine gun
proposed to her that they went home and
drank each other's blood she just kind
of like said that with no explanation no
other context given
she simply assumed that everybody would
read that and go oh yeah well they drank
each other's blood
as one does
what she's describing is quite literally
a satanic blood ritual
which should be quite evident especially
because as she says
her boyfriend cuts her chest his chest
open with broken glass and says take my
soul i mean you couldn't be more clear
you wouldn't be more clear if you were
sacrificing a goat on a satanic altar
which maybe is something they do as well
it wouldn't surprise me
now speaking of megan fox's satanism
there was more news in that vein
yesterday so to speak fox also bragged
about dressing her young son up in
women's clothes
here's um the daily wire says
fox said that when her nine-year-old son
noah started expressing his desire to
wear dresses she decided to educate him
with literature made for and made by
transgender individuals
i do have a child that suffered she said
of her son being bullied i have a lot of
worries about that because i just wish
that humanity was not like this although
my kid is so brave and my child is so
brave and i i know that they've joe's
they've chosen this journey for a reason
it's just hard as a mom i bought a bunch
of books that sort of addressed these
things and addressed a full spectrum of
what this is she told publication
so from the time they were very young
notice how she's using they to refer to
her son i've incorporated those things
into their daily lives so that nobody
feels like they are weird or strange or
different some of the books are written
by transgender children some of the
books are just about how you can be a
boy and wear a dress you can express
yourself through your clothing however
you want now in fact as it turns out
fox's son didn't just randomly decide to
start wearing dresses she's been pushing
this on him for years here she is back
in 2019 on the view
bragging about her son's cross-dressing
habit listen
he's really into fashion and he's the
one like sometimes he'll he'll dress
himself when he likes to wear dresses
sometimes and he'll and i send him to a
really liberal like hippie school but
even
even there here in california he still
has little boys
going like boys don't wear dresses or
boys don't wear pink and so
we're going through that now where i'm
trying to teach him to be confident no
matter what anyone else says
he just he finally he had stopped
wearing dresses for a while he just wore
one two days ago to school and he came
home and i was like how was it did any
of the friends at school have anything
to say and he was like well all the boys
laughed when i came in but he's like but
i don't care i love dresses too much
so megan fox didn't want to have just a
regular boring boy she wanted a
cross-dresser that she could you know
parade around like a fashion accessory
show off to all of her friends talk
about during interviews um i can tell
you right now that
no nine-year-old boy
no six-year-old boy no boyfriend age
just randomly decides that he wants to
wear dresses to school that's the
product of lifelong conditioning in fact
in another interview she said this she
says when i became pregnant with noah i
could feel through my mother's intuition
that he was not subscribing to gender
stereotypes so i decided to provide an
environment for him early on that would
allow him to discover how he wanted to
express himself so through her mother's
intuition in the womb
she decided that her son is non-binary
and provided in environment
from birth to facilitate that
and what do you know now her kid wears
dresses who could have guessed
now she is the bad guy in this scenario
of course not the other boys at school
laughing at her son i feel bad first i
feel really bad for her son on a lot of
different levels
um i mean he's got this blood drinking
freak of a mother
and i feel bad for him
but in terms of getting laughed at at
school like in fact it is ridiculous for
a boy to wear dresses
the other boys are not wrong for finding
it silly
on the you know on the few occasions
when my own children
have encountered and seen this kind of
thing just out in public
um
and they've talked to me about it and
they've said oh that's silly and i said
you're right it is silly it's very silly
for boys to dress like girls it's a very
silly thing
because that's how i want them to
understand it
the boys supposedly bullying her son
actually have his well-being more in
mind than she does even if they don't
realize it
because they're pushing him towards
normalcy and masculinity which is good
because he's a boy and that's who he is
and he should be encouraged to accept
who he is
she's pulling in the other direction for
her own narcissistic self-serving
reasons that's the common theme here
um narcissism self-worship even though
megan fox literally participates in
blood drinking rituals she still is not
i mean probably not anyway
a what we might call theological
satanist she probably doesn't explicitly
worship the theological devil
she might she probably doesn't the most
common form of satanism is this
especially in hollywood it's
self-worship
um
and that is satanism in its rawest form
it's not worshipping the devil outright
but worshipping yourself
in that sense modern leftism is satanism
it's indistinguishable from satanism it
puts the self at the center of
everything the center of the universe
everything and everyone exists to serve
to subordinate itself to the self
and the self itself exists
for itself
it has no higher purpose beyond itself
for megan fox even her child exists as a
mere prop a thing to be used
dressed up paraded around and so on
and that
certainly first and foremost is why she
is today finally canceled and we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 22. hey
there this is john bickley dailywire
editor-in-chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode the great
american migration massachusetts parents
sue a school district over its gender
identity policies and what's next for
elon musk and twitter
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire